[inaudible].
It's a challenge for you.
I'll show you.
Finish watching this video goes your
kitchen and open the fridge.
Then try to find something that has been
produced outside of your country.
If you're watching this video from a
European country,
tried to find some product produced
outside of the European Union,
I bet she probably can't even find it.
Maybe this doesn't surprise you.
Well,
if you think about it a little more
considered that your mobile phone has
been manufactured in more than 20
different countries.
The trousers you're wearing right now,
we're probably manufactured in a country
like China or Bangladesh,
and maybe the company you work for is
also foreign.
I mean,
there's no surprises there,
right?
I mean,
we will live in a globalized economy.
Nonetheless.
Food is the exception to the rule.
Really,
agriculture is an industry that is
completely protected from foreign
competition and make no mistake here.
This has nothing to do with Donald
Trump.
In fact,
if you think he's the creator of trade
was,
well,
your actually absolutely wrong.
Actually,
the primary sector exists in a never
ending cold war.
That's why from time to time we see
headlines like this one
war rips through farm world,
soybean hog prices fall,
or maybe this one cuts import tariffs in
a bid to end.
Banana wars are morven tariffs out.
In fact,
tariffs aren't just one of the many
tools you use to attack foreign markets
bands.
They're not even the deadliest.
Here's an example.
American spends more than $20 billion a
year in subsidies that are farmers
sounded like a lot to you.
Well,
not compared to the whopping $72 billion
that the EU spends in subsidies every
single year.
And how you might be wondering,
well,
what do the subsidies have to do with
trade was,
and the answer that as well.
A lot example,
this milk rake you see on the screen
here is worth an average of 60 euro
cents and a Spanish supermarket from
those 60 cents.
The Spanish Pharma would get 30 cents,
but it's actual revenue is going to be
44 cents.
And why is this?
Well,
that's because the European Union will
give them a subsidy of 14 cents per
liter,
thanks to this grand.
So the farmer can sell cheap and still
make money.
And this is why Europe doesn't need to
buy African sugar despite it being
cheaper or even more surprisingly,
why American or European producers can
snatch the competition from African
markets despite there having higher
wages.
But hold on a minute here because things
are about to change.
And this time the free market champion
is not America.
It's not Japan or even Australia dare
viewer,
despite what you might expect if there
is somebody willing to start an
agricultural.
It's actually the European.
Yeah,
union.
Well macron breaks French taboo on farm
subsidies.
A French president questioning these
subsidies on farming is like a hipster
closing his instagram accounts.
It's something that's never been done
before for years.
The so called Common Agricultural
Policy,
also known as the CAAP has been one of
the pillars of the European Union and
France is by far its biggest supporter.
But like I said,
things that are about to change.
So now the question becomes is you're
really ready to liberalize its
agricultural sex up.
Oh,
we about to see the ends of the food
trade wars.
And most importantly of all here is this
good or bad news swell.
In this video we are going the answer
all of these questions,
but before we do,
let's take a look back.
The history
he used for,
let's imagine that we have a wheat farm
in Essex in the UK.
We harvest the crop and go to sell it to
the month.
Yes,
boss time we did,
we received 175 pounds per ton.
So it makes sense to expect to sell it
for a similar price this time around,
right?
Well actually no,
I mean maybe this time the market price
for wheat is actually just 150 pounds
per ton.
This is a reality that every farmer
faces every year.
By contrast,
the price of an iphone,
it doesn't really change much over time.
So if we sell I phones,
we can make good predictions about our
income,
but wheat,
corn oil,
or any other commodity can change their
market price from one day to the next.
And I,
you might be wondering,
well,
why?
Why does this happen?
What is the difference between wheat and
it's an iphone?
While the differences that commodities
at the same everywhere.
Maybe you eat some bread today.
Could you tell me where the weeks it was
made from?
What's produced?
Well,
probably not.
The same goes with the oil used to
produce the gasoline that you put in
your car.
You don't know if it's Saudi or Canadian
and you don't really care.
You just want it to be as absolutely
cheap as possible.
Nonetheless,
there I'll just a few dinosaur juice
producers.
Meanwhile,
there are many producers of wheat,
corn,
and potatoes,
so if one big producer had a good
harvest,
that's going to affect that market price
for everybody.
And then of course you've got to add to
this,
the weather,
too little rain,
too much rain or an unusually cold.
Windsor can be enough to kill off all of
your revenue.
Nonetheless,
we need agriculture because
unfortunately you cannot eat oil or only
phones.
So how can we keep eating while farmers
don't staff?
Now this might sound like a stupid
question,
but belief knee,
it's one of the hardest problems in
economics as well.
This is where that common agricultural
policy that we mentioned comes into
play.
This is how the European Union protects
the farmers.
When we talk about the CAAP,
we're talking about the cornerstone of
the European Union.
It was the thing even before the
Schengen area or the eurozone were even
born.
Ashley,
do you know who the father of the CIP
was?
Well,
yeah.
It was that French president,
Charles de [inaudible]
gold
nation has no friends,
only interests.
Charles did God.
Now,
if you've been subscribed to visual
politic for a while,
you already know that Charles,
the goal was not exactly a big fan of
the free markets.
Well,
actually he wasn't really a big fan of
anyone except himself.
Really.
This is why we're in France,
became a member of the European single
market.
What would later become the European
Union.
He added a condition.
He basically said,
all right,
we're going to sign up,
but you got to promise us that nobody's
going to become our competition for
farmers.
All right,
and basically that salvage the Apu was
born a policy that is so intervention
list.
It makes Bernie Sanders look blank.
Warren Buffett
basically
in order to compensate for potential
losses when market prices go down,
the European Union gives them direct
cash.
For example,
if you have a bond with cows in Spain,
Brussels will still give you cash
straight away for each and every calvet
you own.
And if you want to buy a milking machine
that is going to make you more
presumptive,
well Brussels is going to help you with
that.
Sue,
this way,
Europe is not only guaranteeing your
income,
but it's also helping it to protect you
from American or African producers.
And as you might have already imagined,
all of this aid costs say it's a load of
money.
So if you want to get a better idea
during the 1990s the caap comprised 80%
of the whole European budgets and even
now when Europe is bigger and it's got
more stuff to do,
the CAAP,
it still makes up 40% of all you
spending and surprise surprise there I
guess which comes from,
he receives most of the aids.
Of course it's France,
but hold on just a moment because things
they do not stop right here beyond his
direct aid.
Europe also has other tactics to avoid
price fluctuations as well as quotas and
tariffs.
For example,
in order to avoid a price drop in milk,
Europe used to put a production limits
on each country.
That means that you couldn't produce
more than a certain number of liters and
it's of course he was benefiting the
most from these production quotas.
Well,
of course it was the country of
croissant and the guests.
As you can imagine,
this milk quota,
it created all kinds of problems among
the other members.
And this is why despite French pressure,
Europe had to put an end to all of this
end of European milk quotas,
a new era for the French dairy sector.
And of course we also have the tariffs
tariffs.
They're like sniper bullets designed to
stop very specific products from getting
into European markets.
For example,
imagine that you are an Argentinian
coffee producer.
If you want to sell your law coffee,
meaning you take it from the plant and
the sellers Europe,
they got no problem.
Zero tariffs for you.
And why is that?
Well,
it's because no European country grows
coffee,
but if you want to sell this coffee and
it's already toasted and processed form,
well good luck to you.
You're going to have to pay a tariff of
7.5%
and why is that?
Well,
because Europe has factories that
process and toast coffee and they just
don't really like competition boss.
I knew what you're thinking right now.
Oh,
that evil European Union,
that punishment,
the third wells,
those Brussels bureaucrats,
they just want to destroy free trade.
Well,
I've actually got bad news for you
because the reality is that every
country on the planet does the exact
same thing.
In fact,
when it comes to tariffs,
Europe is actually one of the most open
regions.
For example,
if the same farmer wants to sell his
coffee in Japan,
he's going to have to pay a 20% tariff
if he wants to sell bananas.
Then he asked to pay between 40 and 50%
depending on the season as what about
America is a land of the free?
Well,
it's actually kind of the same.
There.
Almost no country is willing to leave
its farmers alone in order to compete
with fat competition.
Nonetheless,
all of this can change and why?
Well,
let's have a look at that.
At times for protectionism,
every year Europe spends over $72
billion subsidizing its own farmers.
There's,
as you can imagine,
not all the country.
Then there's paid the same amount.
Just have a look at this chart here.
You can see the main contributors.
That is the countries that pay more than
what they get.
Surprise,
surprise here.
Who is the third biggest caap nets?
Congenita.
Well,
of course that's the United Kingdom.
[inaudible]
Shane's at will no longer be a member of
the club.
As you can imagine,
this leaves a whole of more than a 12
billion euros.
This is why many are suggesting that
other countries have to start paying
more to keep the spending where it used
to be.
Yeah.
Pin Commission urges you countries to
pay more into budget nonetheless,
who really wants to pay more.
It's a time when you're a skeptic are
stronger than ever and no politician can
really come back to his own country and
say,
hey,
guess what guys?
Without your wallet,
because we got to pay more for being in
the EU.
It's not going to go down well.
So if you do the math,
you realize that there's only really one
option.
Yeah.
Musters plans.
It's payments to Europe's biggest farms,
basically Europe hat to reduce the
direct aid given to the farmers.
And they've started with the wealthiest
ones since they're the ones who needed
them the least.
But the biggest surprise came with
Emmanuel macron speech.
Everybody in Brussels might expect from
stupid come out as the biggest old
school crp supporter.
Right?
Let's mcallen.
Well,
he's got other priorities and this means
a green light to cut aid in the future.
Meanwhile,
trade deals being struck in fashion.
Ooh.
And Mexico agreed to new free trade
pact.
Yes.
He has someone not only talking about
Mexico here,
I mean look at this new,
yes,
pn union rush to promote.
It's preliminary free trade agreement
with Japan by stressing the benefits for
you farmers.
Yes,
stiff us slowly.
The European Union is reducing
subsidies,
reducing tariffs and getting rid of
production quotas and I know what you're
probably thinking right now.
You're thinking,
come on Simon.
A,
you're rarely telling us that brexit is
the only reason for this change.
Well,
no,
I'm Saturday.
In fact,
there are two other important reasons.
On the one hand is European agriculture
is already more productive than
elsewhere.
This video we told you about the
Netherlands being one of the biggest
agricultural powerhouses.
In fact,
they have what we call the food silicon
valley.
Okay?
In fact is of bad.
She is or Ribera del Duero wine can be
found almost everywhere and they all
come from Europe.
In other words,
you're a,
doesn't need to protect its own markets
anymore,
but instead sign lots of trade deals and
I know what you might be thinking right
now.
We'll farmers be happy when they stop
getting all of these subsidies from
Brussels.
Well,
the reality is no,
but the question really is,
does actually matter.
Look,
peasants unions,
they used to have a big political grip
during the 60s when the goal was the
French president.
France had millions of people working in
the primary sector.
Now their ons,
even 3% of the population working there.
This means way less political sway and
weighed us votes.
But not only that,
who do you think these European farmers
vote for?
Francis disillusioned farmers turn to Le
Pen.
Exactly.
Basically the biggest place for
euroskeptic parties to get their votes
are rural areas where farmers live.
So if you're a European politician and
he wants to make your vote as happy,
you're really kind of do want to pay
more attention to the urban europeanist
voters instead of the rural euro skeptic
ones and come on now because the average
city guy,
they don't know what the caap even.
Yeah.
Is,
and this leads us to our question for
you.
Does the CAAP have any future whatsoever
in Europe?
Will we see greater liberalization of
agriculture in Europe as well as the
rest of the world?
Well,
please leave your answer in the comment
section below.
Also,
please do visit our friends at the
reconsidered media podcast.
They provided the vocals in this episode
that were not mine.
Don't forget to check it up.
Take three on page where you can support
our channel and gain access to some
exclusive contents.
And also as always,
give us a thumbs up and subscribe and
I'll see you next time.
[inaudible].